I got a fly today dude I hate here's who
I don't like on the plane okay be a
better air buddy don't be this person
the person that keeps their freaking
window open when everybody else window
is closed
how you gonna keep you [__] window
open what are you looking at you at 30
37 you're at 37,000 feet what you
peeking around at you [__] peeping
air tom you looking at cloud tops what
are you doing you [__] you trying to
buy a Care Bear what are you looking for
close your dang window because the light
is coming in and it's ruin everybody
else's experience everybody trying to
[__] rest you know you got this guy
the user there's like an Asian guy he
sleeps like this he makes his own you
know you got that you know you'll have a
kind of a rubenesque kind of black lady
and she just she got on five of those
you know the sultry silky face shades
you know you got the old white guy and
here he got it imagine you know you got
a child and they beaten a [__] drum
both their pants unconscious and he
somebody gave a child a [__] drum on
a plane what the [__] you know when a
child gets a drum never bruh never
except when a and then when they in the
war and they got to send a little child
out there were two drum and that child
is popped off you know what I'm saying
but that's you know that's the sacrifice
that they make you know one love but you
don't ever give a child a [__] drum
you idiot and then everybody trying to
get the rest even the pilots up there
rest and you know they got copilot so
they you know they rested on each other
the two of them everybody's sleeping the
cart lady she coming down he's sleeping
you know the cart guy he's
he's sleeping everybody resting and then
one [__]
gotta leave their window whoa Wow and
that [__] ruins everybody know how to do
air travel shut your window you freaking
mutant a Craig Euler and watch your life
change for the better you know what I'm
talking about praise God
Wow you know it's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options watch
one this one or this one